all right john we made it to the finale
why don't you take it away for us tell
the people what they need to know guys
thank you for joining us if you like
these reactions hit that like button
first and foremost it's what helps out
the most with the algorithm also
remember to subscribe click that
notification bell for whenever the next
reaction is up for whatever the next
reaction is gonna be and for anybody
who's wondering i know season two is
already out on netflix it's been for a
long time but we are gonna take a little
break from the show we've got a whole
bunch of other coverage to do we will
pick it back up at some point to be
determined but for right now if you're
wondering next week where's kingdom
season 2 episode 1 it's gonna be a
little bit of a wait so hopefully this
will hold you over in the meantime and
as always full length watch alongs where
you sync up with the time code for
kingdom those are over at our patreon
page got a bunch of shows that you can
check out with us both stream along and
reaction highlights included it's a lot
of fun and last but not least thanks to
the team over at prepper for cutting
these highlights down all season doing a
bang-up job let's get into the
[Music]
i hope you die
i hope all those bodies come out of the
lake and get you
sergeant
is
please you must stay till nightfall
after
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
m
that's why he's being so weirdly cold to
him
man
[Applause]
oh wow
what's going on
foreign
oh my god it might be him because his
wife is being taken care of
the crown prince [ __ ] that's right
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh my god
i'd like to think i'd let them all die
cover the blinds
just don't let them know you're awake
the old structures don't mean anything
come on
you know
you're not going to regret having that
manager
[Music]
if i give birth and it's a girl i don't
want to hear anything about it she just
faking a pregnancy too i guess
keeping up appearances
what happened why stop talking crying i
probably executed it for being a girl
holy christ whoa
there's probably like a pile of girl
babies behind that door
come on
[Music]
movie magic
she was faking the pregnancy
now
foreign
i don't know maybe there's some kind of
special plant life there
maybe it was rendered by a glacier
centuries ago
that's where the false lilies would be
located
saying such
huh
oh yeah that's right she was in that
like ice place before she's putting it
on
no
that's right burn it she was looking for
her
[Music]
ultra zombie crimson head
a sincere noah or just a denial it's a
sun isn't it
probably something like that that he
could never tell anyone about
that
how are they so sure they'll turn up
busan
such a realistic touch just like [ __ ]
bored meaty
foreign
careful guys you could have a gun
horse have been spying on them all this
time
what a respectable horse
you kind of made it over that
yeah
we got around it massage going
horse didn't want to stay off the trail
wow you could tell that from there
[Music]
temperature's gonna end with just a
giant horde coming all right yeah
swallowing up the camera
i think if the [ __ ] could do this every
night yeah i guess until they get here
if they ever get here
hey did the
doctor lady return
no i think they're still up there
and then the zombie switch to daytime
[Music]
what's happening
i feel like something terrible is going
to happen soon
well yeah it's gotta can't make it
through a night this easy
zombies are under my command
what the [ __ ] is going on is he gonna
send an army or some [ __ ] i think they
can move during the day now
[Music]
oh
no stakes have been raised the
temperature oh god
wow
what a tease oh
man oh no
[Music]
everybody got crumbs
did that guy know uh he seems like it
oh
no oh no oh what a nightmare
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
let's wait for the temperature to go
down
[Music]
what's the temperatures disappeared yeah
and what was it all those nights is it
like hot nights or cold
i mean they saw a fire
fire could still scare them off yeah
yeah
one would hope
interesting finale interesting finale
choice
i liked it but i also thought that was
the weakest episode of the six hmm
yeah that's fair it feels like it kind
of leaves off
rather than really builds to some kind
of
punch or crescendo like it's a big
revelation at the end but
i feel like we did a lot of preparing
for just that basically i feel like it
was a lot of preparing for season two
yeah is what it ultimately did yeah
instead of
concluding some type of narrative art
because usually i mean every show
usually
has like you gotta have your
cliffhangers to have people come back
for the next season like i totally get
that i i think that's necessary a lot of
the time too
um
but i also
my personal preference is when i still
feel like there's some type of narrative
arc fulfilled
simultaneously
while
what are
it's like we just finished off on
arcane for example without giving
anything away like while that ends on a
big cliffhanger where the story's not
complete
that ends on a note of characters have
chosen a path they're going to take and
that's a lot of characters trying to
figure out their path
and then here
uh
yeah it felt like it was like plot
mechanisms so i mean i still liked it
just because of the fact that i like
this show a lot already
and
you know like i like the reveals that
you have here of okay they have they
affirm with the queen
how she's faking her pregnancy because
yeah that wasn't making any sense to me
and uh you know especially when they're
looking for a baby
like okay so she must be fake pregnant
and i didn't actually guess that until
like 10 minutes before they revealed it
so she must be fake pregnant uh
the the where the resurrection plants
are because yeah the sci-fi site b cybo
sobia how do you say it i mean
so so be
sobe i think i mean so it's usually like
an a
vowel sound at the end when like he's
calling her name is usually like sobia
so i don't know if it's like that's an
honorific of some kind but the nurse
so yeah i mean the resurrection plant
um
and then of course uh like where the
crown prince is located learning that
there's a mole there
and he in his little group
and
the fact that he found a section of this
massive kingdom where he can you know
lead the way be considered the true
heir to the throne and the real like be
considered crown prince not treated as a
criminal outcast in his own land
so you have that device there's a lot of
like pieces that i think they set up for
this wonderful game of chess they've
been playing here
and yeah it was like a lot of
build up to a revelation moment
and so like the last few minutes were
definitely exciting because you're like
oh [ __ ] they can move during the day
that's insane the temperature rule thing
we gotta i'd like to have a little bit
more of an understanding it's pretty
easy to go when it's night they're here
um
so it must be just when it's cold
because they're in the frozen valley
it's all the fog yeah everything so yeah
it must just be cold temperatures bring
them out
okay
that makes sense yeah so i'm trying to
like look back at all the zombie times i
guess it was never that cold during the
day yeah um
is it something that they've never
talked to i can't even call if they've
ever like discussed the weather yeah and
it's always kind of bright and clear
most daytime scenes yeah i don't know if
they've ever been like it's hot today
yeah we're like yeah some rain
oh you know yeah
it's a rain during the day i'm sure the
zombies would probably come out then
like were there clues that led to that
reveal that i that completely flew over
my head is more i'm not saying they're
not there uh it's something that i never
was mindful of when watching the show so
maybe they're there maybe they're not
well i mean i don't know anything about
the climate in korea
so you know maybe it is just you know
hot during the day cold at night usually
or something like that i mean it's
beyond korea it's also like a different
time period
for the industrial revolution yeah
before before the non-existent global
warming could take effect yeah yeah
and the earth was still flat yeah that's
right so yeah you know like they had
they they had some good stuff in here uh
for sure and and i i felt as a narrative
piece because i thought every episode
was a really
just a truly strong narrative piece
that this one actually left me the most
like i was a little let down i thought
of finale this would probably be one of
the strongest ones um don't get me wrong
i was getting excited for season two
like
that ending makes me go [ __ ] we got
watch season two
um
but i feel like that's mainly what it
did and it didn't really
it felt like it was a giant post-credits
scene
i felt like we watched
with some plot developments of course
they're i'm not going to say it's void
of that um but it did feel like we're
planning a lot of seats to make you make
sure you come back for the next season
whereas i feel like generally the show's
really good at planting seeds and make
you come back for the next episode while
fulfilling a really good story for
each isolated episode yeah i mean it
does it does a nice job of getting you
excited for the increased stakes but it
does also feel like
yeah there's somebody got a finale
episode that usually feels kind of
singular whereas this doesn't feel that
way much at all and i mean you're still
getting new revelations and you're still
finding out new threads to be worried
about and you're being introduced to new
ideas so it's almost just feels like
and that's us not to use this phrase to
slag it but you know like it almost
feels like another episode
i think it didn't feel like filler just
felt like just like the next episode
rather than all this the finale you know
i felt like they were padding some run
time
that was fair
because a lot of the things that were
being established i thought were
yeah it felt more like a setup felt more
like season two would have started and
this would have been the first episode
yeah yeah yeah and
it just kind of works differently in the
frame than the
in one's own framing of what you're
about to watch you know
but i don't know maybe everyone loves
this and then we're just the only two
who's like what the hell man
where's the big old crescendo
other than the last couple minutes
i guess the narrative arc would be in
the form of the crown prince finally
having a place of
uh because who's the who's the guy who
was like his mentor lord on
uh what was it on lord on lord on yeah
uh with with on and how his uh
wherever there's
i don't i like i can see the spelling
and i have no idea how to say it
that's pretty much my association with
all the words here um
yeah like wherever they're at i guess
the the narrative arc is
how he's become like the crown prince
leader for this faction and this pretty
much had like this civil war now with
using the the epidemic as the main tool
of
where do you where do we steer this this
lifeless army
yeah you know
so and i love that
element of it of
the the the
uh [ __ ] cho hawk
his name choc yeah show hawk
the main guy who's got the chip on his
shoulder who's yeah the camera and the
king around in a box and who's standing
there looking out the guy who has the
daughter who's like i love you daddy and
he's like i wield all power [ __ ]
protect me my ass
yeah
just trying to help i help you you don't
help me
yeah yeah flip every relationship loves
everything she says you have to be like
shut up
this is all me saw me don't ever delude
yourself to think that you've got any
power in this situation now go have a
boy
don't come back to you've given birth to
a boy
i'm just straight up executing the women
yeah what a bunch of [ __ ] just let
them have the the baby
yeah
at that point just let them have the
babies yeah i mean that like they had a
lot of like sinister elements and beats
like that that i thought were striking
it's weird because you know like this
episode doesn't feel like an exclamation
point on the season but there are still
moments like that that are very chilling
like yeah they're they're just
discarding these women and their babies
and you know that sets up some tension
for you know what we know about muy
young's wife and then there's that whole
thing where they actually you know
execute the the you know uh the you know
the folks from the capital who are
coming to you know
put uh prince chang into custody
you know like that was a pretty big i
felt like that was the most sort of
momentous moment of like oh man they're
just executing all these guys like this
is a this is a direct bit of confidence
on you know the crown prince from at
least lord on and his people so like
that was cool that's what i mean by the
narrative piece being with crown prince
finally
having an established
truly established rule of leadership
yeah
with a with an audience
versus
where you start off with this show and
he's at the
he's got like four people who like him
yeah and i mean even for him it's
something that we've seen him do before
it's just now there's more
legitimate eyes from you know the
leadership around to behold him actually
stepping up being like hey man you're
not doing your job at all you're not
protecting any of these people i'm gonna
protect these people and also yeah
establishing i mean they're you know the
more i think about it the more i like it
actually especially because
of how
ye
the
the jew
i just wanted to say
i think i think it would be true i'm
gonna but every time i say it i'm gonna
think j-e-w and it's just gonna make me
laugh you could say jew no no no that's
not happening today hard jays always
shock jewish men
jokes
shmuley moises
insert various other jewish names joe
hawk weinberg
yeah uh-huh
definitely
no any rabbi
we've offended both the korean i think
it's probably for a common korean name i
think in the american it might be hakshu
cho if you because cho is the family
name right and then and then hakju i
think is his first fair enough is his
like individual name anyway but you know
go with rabbi
weinberg or whatever you said anyway
when adam sandler was saying yes when
you see adam sandler casting everyone
out
and
you know blocking everyone off where he
welcomes everyone in and strategizes a
way to save them
yeah like these are qualities that i
really loved about it especially when
you see
how they strategically work together to
let's build some boats guys we got a few
hours let's get in place let's get
everyone ready let's get them fed you
know i like traps i like seeing i did
like seeing all that and it was it was
nice i i guess there was
i guess my mindset for an expectation of
a finale kind of uh
intervened
i think there's something interesting
about the fact that you watch them mount
this huge offensive and and defensive
and you you know they bring this whole
elaborate system of yeah boats and traps
and people on the wall and everyone's
ready
and it's like i i appreciate and respect
what makes your stomach drop about the
whole thing where was like oh we made it
without incident and it was fine oh [ __ ]
now they're coming like that
does pack a punch but at the time of
watching it it is sort of like
oh we just got through the night and it
was fine
also the shortest one
this is like a 39 minute episode or
something it's a short episode
um where the other ones were like pretty
solid 50 to 60 minutes yeah so that's
how i meant by i felt like they were
kind of
sometimes it felt like they were letting
some things linger on a little bit
longer than they normally would
makes me wonder when they found out they
got their season renewal
yeah maybe they held some stuff to go
into season two like all guns blazing or
something
yeah
as i think in the original right the
queen was supposed to step into the room
and slip on that water that's right and
then bang her head and hit her head yeah
and then become a zombie on the spot
yeah
zombie you know he has he [ __ ] you
carrying around the [ __ ]
camper zombie his daughter zombie
just to make some giant elaborate plan
zombie kingdom they're alive look at
them see everyone in power isn't ever
why did i do this it's just all it's all
this one guy trying to pull the strings
be like no no they're alive
this is what they decreed i'm just the
mouthpiece man you want to go visit the
cake be my guest
bring something to eat for him
yeah i hope that's where it goes i hope
it's just like one big puppet show of
this guy trying to keep a bunch of
zombie officials in line he's got them
all chained to their posts
everyone and all the civilians know it's
what the truth is all the amazing we
know they're affected no
no come on no don't leave there's messy
eaters you guys
and then the whole squirrel will change
and it'll just be the benny hill music
over and over again so he tries and
tries to be like weekend at bernie's
yeah weekend at the kingdom we can
discuss
yeah and he's just got sunglasses and
hats
just running around the room trying to
pump in each other i'm trying not to get
bit in the process i think this this
this version of kingdom is what i really
want to see
can't you guys see why we were a little
let down by the finale we had such high
hopes of where we thought it was in the
kingdom we
really
sometimes our expectations are just
never met
the weekend at the crown princes man
let's do it i want it
all right on that note keep a lookout
for when we continue season two of
kingdom
good times
[Music]
you